governor of California Gavin Newsom did
an interview on MSNBC with Jin Saki and
I want to take a look at two moments
from this
the first he just very accurately uh
diagnosis and raises alarm about the
moment that we're in in this country
where rights are being rolled back and
people are being targeted in some
terrifying ways take a look at this and
then we'll discuss
also don't get what's going on in this
country I don't get why everybody's not
doing what we're doing I don't
understand it do people understand it's
not just about Mar-A-Lago it's not just
about what's happening in Washington DC
or what's happening in New York Court
with the district attorney there's
something deep and serious that's
happening across this country all the
progress the last half century is being
rolled back in these states in real time
in just the last few years I don't think
people fully understand the rights
regression individual liberties on civil
rights on voting rights and the
gerrymandering that's happening out here
on just the assault on the
African-American Community The Assault
on the gay lesbian bisexual and trans
Community the number one issue of the
day it seems to be getting rid of the
word latinx in Arkansas and number two
getting rid of drag shows it's a serious
moment in American history and yet we're
so consumed respectfully by the
spectacles
in Washington that I as an American feel
compelled as a governor to call that out
and expose some of that in a more
systemic way and forgive me for being
intense about this but everything I have
taken for granted in my life in the last
half century in terms of Rights
expansion not even bring up abortion and
contraception all of that all of that is
in Peril at this moment in my kids they
need if I care about my kids I sure as
I'll better care about what's going on
in Alabama what's going on in
Mississippi in Arkansas and you know
what I'm coming back a much better
Governor because I spent a long weekend
with my kids here I do you took a trip
to Arkansas but uh it's absolutely right
because of the
almost reality TV nature
while drama
um that is American politics right now
it can be easy to get distracted from
some of the significant ways in which
damaging actions are being taken by the
Republican party and buy this modern
right wing that is driving the
Republican party and I think Gavin
Newsom better than a lot of those within
the within the Democratic party is able
to
call attention to that in
uh a tone that matches the moment I
think we see a lot of Democrats
um who maybe they realize the moment
that we're in and maybe they try to call
attention to it but it just doesn't
match in tone in rhetoric the way
uh that it should the moment that we're
in and that's what Gavin Newsom does
very effectively because it's scary
abortion rights
being targeted even though clearly
America is not on board with that with
the way that we are voting
um as he noted the lgbtq community the
refusal to address problems such as gun
violence and racial inequality and
income inequality and on it goes it just
is so enraging that that's what we're
dealing with but it is and we can't let
the Mar-A-Lago debacles those are
important too and Trump's legal troubles
distract from the significant things
that also have to be focused on next
moment from this interview here it
sickens me in my court I'll tell you
um and you would have more insight than
anybody so you can validate
um what happened in Tennessee triggered
this trip
just triggered I I ca I called the White
House full disclosure
um I said I can't take it I can't I got
four yet I can't I was given speeches
the same speech you've seen every
politician give Monterey Park down in
Salinas I gave it prior down in Gilroy
and when I was mayor
we see the dance
I mean I I can't I just can't take it I
can't take it and then to see the same
Governors these were talk about mental
health you know unique apparently in
America to talk about you know our
parents and our family I mean all the BS
and then they claim to care about life
when the number one cause of death for
our children is guns shameful they're
shameful
and it should shock our souls but it's
becoming so normalized it's a matter of
hours now not even days
I mean I thought we would never move on
from Parkland or never move on from
Uvalde never move on from Buffalo I had
to read the manifesto I read the
manifesto from the shooter in Buffalo I
still have chills thinking about that
Manifesto to understand this this is
serious the manifesto allegedly for the
shooter in Tennessee all connected this
broader contagion they don't care about
our kids because if they did they'd ban
these damn weapons of war they would
have background checks they require some
common damn sense they don't so you know
what those kids they were there in the
capital God bless every single one of
them
uh we've talked a good bit about this
subject on today's show but I just don't
know how else to say it it's so true
what he's saying that
if you're gonna say you're the party of
protecting the kids as the GOP has been
saying
and then turn around and side with your
distorted this distorted and inaccurate
and correct view of what the Second
Amendment means that it means you can't
regulate at all
uh firearms
over the lives of
children and people of all ages but
because they say they want to protect
the kids
you're not being honest you don't
that's not an authentic motivation for
the things that you're doing it feels
nice to say
whenever
it comes time for
you to demonize lgbtq people
but no it's not an authentic ambition to
protect the kids because you would start
if you cared about that you would start
with the leading cause of death for
children no doubt and so to choose again
the incorrect
interpretation that has been created of
the Second Amendment over the lives of
our children Highlights better than
anything else more accurately than
anything else
the dishonesty of that whole narrative
and
it's sickening to watch
day after day we just got news of
another mass shooting in Louisville
five people dead
and
they're at schools but they're also all
over places at a bank
um
and
there are lives being lost and also the
terror that is injected into just the
lives of people when they know this
could happen anywhere at any time
and all of that is not necessary
it really is not necessary nothing
makes that more clear than the fact that
we're the only country that experiences
when we compare ourselves to other
developed countries
this type of gun violence these numbers
in terms of mass shootings
and to think that's just a coincidence
and the reason why other countries don't
see this gun balance is just because
they don't have problems with mental
health for some magical reason no
it is clear what needs to be done and
it's not being done it's being blocked
from being done by so many within the
Republican Party